what we're going to do in this video is
continue our journey trying to
understand what the expected value and
what the variance of a binomial variable
is going to be or what a what the
expected value or the variance of a
binomial distribution is going to be
which is just the distribution
distribution of a binomial variable and
so like in the last video I have this
binomial variable X that's defined in a
very general sense it's the number of
successes from n trials so it's a finite
number of trials where the probability
of success is equal to P so the
probability is constant across the
trials for each of these independent
trials so the probability of success in
one trial is not dependent on what
happened in the other trials and we also
talked in that previous video where we
talked about the expected value of this
binomial variable is we said hey it
could be viewed that this binomial
variable can be viewed as the sum of n
of what you could really consider to be
a Bernoulli variable here so this
variable this random variable Y the
probability that's equal to 1 you could
view that as a success is equal to P the
probability that it's a failure that Y
is equal to 0 is 1 minus P so you could
view why the outcome of Y is really the
or whether Y is 1 or 0 is really whether
we had a success or not in each of these
trials so if you add up and Y's then you
are going to get X and we use that
information to figure out what the
expected value of X is going to be
because the expected value of y is
pretty straightforward to directly
compute expected value of y it's just
probability weighted outcomes so it's P
times 1 plus 1 minus P 1 minus P times 0
times 0 this whole term is going to be 0
and so the expected value of y is really
just P and so if you said the expected
value of x well that's just going to be
we could let me just write it over here
this is all review we could say that the
expected value of x is just going to be
equal to we know from our expected value
properties that's going to be equal to
the sum of the expected values of these
and
or you could say it is n times the
expected value times the expected value
of y the expected value of y is P so
this is going to be equal to n times P
now we're going to do the same idea to
figure out what the variance of X is
going to be equal to because we could
see we know Farmar variance properties
you can't do this with standard
deviation but you could do it with
variance and then once you figure out
the variance you just take the square
root for the standard deviation the
variance of X is similarly going to be
the sum of the variances of these
endwise so it's going to be similarly n
times the variance n times the variance
of Y so this all boils down to what is
the variance of Y going to be equal to
so let me scroll over a little bit get a
little bit of more real estate and I
will figure that out right over right
over here all right so we want to figure
out the variance of Y so variance of Y
is going to be equal to what well here
it's going to be the probability squared
distances from the expected value so we
have a probability of P where what is
going to be our squared distance from
the expected value well we have we're
going to get a 1 with a probability of P
so in that case our distance from the
mean or from the expected value we're at
1 the expected value we already know is
equal to P so that's that for that
possible outcome the squared distance
times its probability weight and then we
have actually let me scroll over a
little I'll just do it right over here
plus we have a probability of 1 minus P
1 minus P for the other possible outcome
so in that outcome we are at 0 and the
difference between 0 and our expected
value well that's just going to be 0
minus P and once again we are going to
square that distance and so this is the
expression or the scale square that
quantity and so this is
expression for the variance of Y and we
can simplify a little bit so this is all
going to be equal to so let me just P
times 1 minus P squared and then this is
just going to be P squared times 1 minus
P plus P squared times 1 minus P and
let's see we can factor out a P times 1
minus P so what is that going to be left
with so if we factor out a P times 1
minus P here we're just going to be left
with a 1 minus P and if we factor out a
P times 1 minus P here we're just going
to have a plus P these two cancel out
this is just this whole thing is just a
1 so you're left with P times 1 minus P
which is indeed the variance for
binomial variable we actually prove that
in other videos like I said doesn't hurt
to see it again but there you have it we
know what the variance of Y is it is P
times 1 minus P and the variance of X is
just n times the variance of Y so there
we go we deserve a little bit of a
drumroll the variance of X is equal to n
times P times 1 minus P so if we were to
take the concrete example of the last
video where if I were to take 10 free
throws so each trial is a shot is a free
throw so if I were to take 10 free
throws and my probability of success is
0.3 I have a 30 percent free throw
percentage the variance that I would
expect to see so in that case the
variance if X is the number of free
throws I make after these ten shots my
variance will be 10 times 0.3 0.3 times
1 minus 0.3 so 0.7 and so that would be
what this right over here so this would
be equal to 10 times 0.3 times 0.7 it
times 0.2 1 so my variance in this
situation is going to be equal to two
point one it is equal to
to point one and if I wanted to figure
out the standard deviation of this right
over here I would just take the square
root of this so that's what the standard
deviation just take the square root of
this expression right over here